Hey, welcome to 40 Days of Holiness. Grab your workbook, and let's get started.
Romans chapter eight, verse nine says that if anyone does not have
the spirit of Christ, the Holy Spirit, he is none of his.
All right? So God gifts to us the presence of the Holy Spirit to
make us holy. So how many Christians have the Holy Spirit?
100%. There aren't any Christians that don't have the Holy Spirit.
But that sanctifying influence, that empowering of
God's will in your life, has a will, and his will
is that your connection to holiness would not stop there, that it would continue
on in faith to deeper levels of holiness.
So in the rest of this 40 days, I'm going to talk to you about being filled
with the Holy Spirit. Now, not in the sense that some Pentecostal people would
say, they mean it where it's like you get hit on the forehead, and you fall down in
some kind of foolishness. That's not what I'm talking about.
I mean the full presence of the Holy Spirit.
Having access to full portions of your spirit that
grant you deeper levels of holiness that God has available for
you after you are saved. I'm talking about increasing.
Like that. I know I'm talking to some people here who are not from a Wesleyan or
Arminian background, and you're wondering, "Okay, is this for me?
This is not what I've been taught." Let me read a quote to you from
the well-known Reformed teacher, Martyn Lloyd-Jones. All right?
Martyn Lloyd-Jones said in a chapel sermon one time, he said this: "I want to talk
to you today about the baptism of the Holy Spirit.
You may call it what you want, but I want to know, have you
experienced the fullness of the Spirit?
I know all of you listening to me here come, as I do, from a Reformed
background," he said, "but it's not good enough.
I know that all of you would want to say to my question about the Holy Spirit,
'Well, I got that at conversion. We got it all at conversion.
There's no need for any more experience.'"
And he said, "I have only one question to ask you.
If you got it all at conversion, where in God's name is
it?"
Now, that's a worthy question, isn't it?
Remember the levels of holiness in the Old Testament covenant that God made with
his people that we talked about a few days ago? Well, I've got good news.
God's got more levels for you, more intimacy, more
filling, more purity, more power, more separation to his ownership, more
fellowship than ever before. He's got more for
you.
And once you see it, the New Testament is full of it, but there is something
you're going to have to change in order to see it. All right?
I have a pair of tinted glasses here, and when I wear them, everything
looks the color of the glasses. Each one of you is
also wearing a pair of glasses that colors what you
read from the scripture. In theology, we call it
hermeneutics. It's the science and art of
interpreting the Bible.
Now, we each interpret the Bible through the glasses that we're
wearing. Let me talk to you about the ones you're wearing. Okay?
Most people read the scriptures with a
deprivation hermeneutic. We, as humans, are deprived of the strength to
obey. We're depraved and evil, and it's terrible, and we can't fix ourselves.
And that's true for those of us who don't know the Lord and who are not saved.
We can't save ourselves. We can't bring ourselves to God.
We're powerless against sin. Those things are all true of sinners.
But here's the problem. The deprivation hermeneutic leaves out
one key doctrine, the doctrine of grace.
Grace is undeserved kindness. It is also enabling
power given to us by God to enable us to do his will.
The Apostle Paul says in 1 Corinthians 10:15, "But by the
grace of God, I am what I am, and his grace to me was not without
effect. No, I worked harder than all of them, yet not I,
but the grace of God that was with me." So you see, God's grace is not
just forgiveness for when we fall short.
It is enabling power to rise to what we ought to
be. That's what grace means. And if you're wearing your deprivation
glasses while you're reading the scripture,
if you're wearing those, you'll see everything without the
possibilities of grace. So every time you read a command of scripture
pointing out the need to be holy, it doesn't come across as hopeful.
It comes across as one more reminder of, "I can't do that."
Right? So the point of God's calls to holiness becomes
different. It just becomes a reminder of, "Well, I guess I can never really be
holy," because of the glasses that you're wearing.
So here's the glasses you're going to need to wear. All right?
I want you to change out your deprivation glasses for
possibility glasses. All right? I want you to change them out for
possibility glasses. When you're wearing these kind of glasses, you
may see what one of my professors in Bible college, Reverend Larry Smith,
used to call the possibilities of grace.
When God says, "Be holy," what do you see?
Well, if you're wearing deprivation glasses, you'll say, "Oh, well, there's one
more way in which I'll never measure up until I get to heaven."
Right? Can't be holy, can't do that.
If you're wearing possibility glasses, though, you would say, "Oh,
thank you, Lord. Yes, Lord, produce that in me through the
power of the Holy Spirit, through your grace active in my life." I
cannot overemphasize this enough.
I am going to dive into serious Bible exposition here for the
next 15 days, and it is crucial that you understand
that my goal is to tell you things that God
can actually do in your life, helping you reach
levels of holiness and purity and humility and joy that you've
never before imagined were possible.
So to make that change today,
we're going to have to talk about what's next tomorrow.
I'm sorry, to make that change, I want you to make this change today, and
we'll talk about what's next tomorrow.
So
take a look at the glasses that you're wearing and say, "Have I been wearing
deprivation glasses, where I look at the scripture and say, 'Well, guess that means
I can't do that. Guess that means I can't do that.' Or have I been wearing
possibility glasses?"
If you interpret the commands of God
in the light of the impossibilities in the character of
man,
then
you'll always believe that we're just going to never make it.
You're never going to be really holy.
But if you interpret the impossibilities of
man through the possibilities of grace and the power
of God,
then you begin to understand God does not command
that which he does not enable.
If he says, "Be holy,"
he can make you holy.
He can do it. And if he says, "Be holy all the way to the core
of your being," he can make you holy all the way to there.
And if he says, "This is the way I'm going to enable you to act," he
can make it possible for you to actually do that. All right?
So take time today to think through it and thank the Lord for it
and make a change to some possibility glasses. All right?
And I'll see you back here tomorrow.